viana chapoval aux vins est arrivé au
canada en 2013 avec sa famille la jeune
ukrainienne de 19 ans vit la pire
période de son existence fellow c'est
l'heure de savoir qu'est ma famille et
comme en danger est présentement au pied
et on pas de place aux ce qu'il faudrait
rester il n'a presque plus aucune
communication avec ses proches en
ukraine seulement quelques vidéos que sa
famille lui envoie qui la bouleverse
profondément
département ça arrête donc mais
ça recommence elle tente de faire venir
19 membres de sa famille au canada c'est
c'est ma grand mère qui est elle aussi
elle est sociale de l'église et les
délais administratifs sont interminables
chaque attente sa peur ça peut briser
l'écart ça peut détruire une famille
si c'est pas celle d' accélérer d'un
jour dinner sa de l'importance la preuve
que chaque minute est importante en
temps de guerre son oncle nicolaï a été
tué hier qui a trouvé un sauveur qui
était complètement brûlé les quatre
personnes qui étaient avec rires
complètement brûlé presque pas réclamé
sable jeu celui qui était projeté de la
toîle a été reconnu sa femme et ses
trois enfants ce qu'ils h dans une
église de marioupol je sais que mon
frère était décédée hier mais
aujourd'hui j'ai rentré à le travail
parce que je sais je n'ai pas le droit
de les reposer présentement ils ont tout
détruit les maisons le travail elle est
tout ce qui est long on a eu ces sept
disparus olena ébranlé par les
événements et pleure ottawa d'accélérer
le processus pour rapatrier les réfugiés
du craignait si on peut l'amener plus
tôt possible ils ont arrêté de attendre
sept danger lpl commencer la vie normale
son beau frère peter simin keane se
cache lui aussi sa femme et ses filles
sont en exil en hongrie en sécurité pour
le moment
je trouve ça difficile d'être loin de ma
famille nous voulons venir au canada
nous sommes prêts à travailler pour un
pays nous on va se sentir en sécurité
ottawa dit travailler activement à
accélérer les processus pour rapatrier
les réfugiés du craignait affaires
mondiales canada n'a pas retourné nos
appels aujourd'hui ici marie michel
lauzon radio canada montréal